ابراهيم عبد الله
الكربوي
[موسيقى]
غلي يابا ايدي صارت
قلت له كفي بدنا ناكل خبز جرقه ولا حمراء
بدنا نعيش
[موسيقى]
انا بفضل الامور يعني اذا حدا يجيني هون
وبده ياخذ اولادي افضل اني اموت قدام
اولادي ويشوفوني اني متت خالص
ولا افضل اني اخليهم ورايا
[موسيقى]
بدي اعملها باربعين دولار للطفل الواحد
بحاول اني انسى الوضع انسى انه اولادي
مرضانين يعني عايشين ضغط نفسي عايشين ضغط
على سوريا صعب اني ارجع جوزي مطلوب
احتياطي اذا بدي اروح على سوريا جوزي
بيروح مين بدي اعيش الاولاد هذول بسوريا
ببقى هون اولادي عم بيموتوا قدام عيني
يعني ما بعرف شو بدي اعمل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والله صار الخوف وين ما اروح احس مرافقني
يعني صارت عندي عقده نفسيه يقسم من الحياه
ميت قلب ميت بلاكن عايشه كرامه لاولادي
هذولا احس حالي راح اظل اجي بهالخيمه
وساكته
[موسيقى]